good morning believe nation today's
message is have an impact over to you
Chris Sacca
I wake up every mood this recipe vigo
too many investors invest in the things
that they just like and are comfortable
with and are within their own little
bubble and yet I think the distinction
we like to make is invest in things that
we know we can personally impact the
outcome up so I everyone could be
talking about the hot biotech deal and
it might be on the verge of AB curing
cancer but I cannot do anything to
advance the mission of a biotech company
quite literally and so we pass as cool
as it may seem if I'm going to mooch I
may as well mooch in the public markets
right and just throw darts and ride the
greens in red so if I believe that I can
take something that's already a good
company and just make it a little more
likely to be a success then that's a
rigged game for me it almost feels
unfair right and I can just be that much
more confident that the investors who
give me their money I'm gonna give them
their money back and a lot more after
that so as an investor myself is
something that I look at I want to make
sure that I'm invested into business is
that I believe in that i can add
something to that i can inject some
creativity and leverage what I've done
with my audience in youtube and my
website and not just invest in somebody
because their thing looks cool but I
think the more valuable message to you
guys were probably more in the
entrepreneurial side than the investor
side is you need to apply that same kind
of thinking when you're looking for
investors so when you are going out
looking for somebody to give you money
to launch your business expand your
business especially when you're dealing
with angel investors or venture
capitalists you want the people who can
give you more than just money it may be
great to think about your Uncle Joe or
aunt Jill or whoever it is you know the
dentist down the street or the doctor
that you know where that lawyer friend
of yours to give you money but you don't
want what's called dumb money you don't
want people to just give you money and
that's it because your biggest need is
not just money you want somebody who
cares about your business who doesn't
see it only as an investment who cares
about the mission that you're on and
that can open doors for you that can
give guidance to you right you want
somebody who can ask questions too and
they can give you some mentorship you
want somebody who's going to open up
their rolodex of contacts
and make introductions for you to help
you close new deals to help you get more
media to help you get new suppliers and
get more customers on board and so it
highly highly highly encourage you
anybody was out there trying to raise
money for their business don't bring on
any investor just because you need money
you have to get the right investor on
board and that's hard to do because when
you're struggling when you really need
that cash and it's really hurting your
growth the tendency is I'll take anybody
because I want to ramp up my growth but
you're making a long-term decision based
on short-term needs and the last thing
you want to do is get stuck with an
investor who isn't going to be a fit for
you long-term right they're gonna always
own a piece of your company and the more
and more people that owned a chunk of
your business that don't actually
contribute anything besides money to you
you don't want those guys on your
company at all so the question of a
today is we haven't talked a lot about
investing investments getting investors
into your company I'm curious for you
guys are you looking at angel
investments have you already gone down
that route or not where are you on your
path you're going to self-fund it you're
trying to get investment to try to get
loans we're on your path of raising
capital cheers to find out leave it in
the comments below I also want to give a
quick shadow to end you beer camp Andrew
thank you so much for picking up a cup
of my book your one word it really
really really really means a lot to me
and I hope you enjoy it so thank you
guys again for watching I hope you have
an amazing day I believe in you and hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events vesa
nespresso give me go